We've heard a bit about customers
in the last few segments.
Not surprisingly, customers will
play a huge role in the success or
failure of your business.
Are they giving you money or
aren't they?
There are a few metrics you should
keep in mind in terms of customers,
loyalty, retention,
and acquisition costs.
Customer loyalty measures
the performance of your customers,
how often they purchase,
how often they visit a site,
basically have they made
your product a habit.
Customer retention then
measures the number of users
retained in a given time period.
And this is particularly important for
subscription-based models,
which we'll learn more about later.
You can calculate customer retention
by taking the total number of customers
at the end of the given period and
subtracting the total number of new
customers that you got
during that period.
And you divide that all by the customers
that you had at the start of the period.
Multiply that by 100 and
you'll get a percentage.
Customer acquisition cost,
as the name implies,
is how much you spend
to acquire new users.
You can calculate customer acquisition
cost by taking the total acquisition
expenses and dividing by the total
number of new users in a given period.
Now, what constitutes good for each
of these metrics is really up to you.
Obviously, a 100% customer retention
percentage would be ideal,
but it's also not very likely.
You'll be referring to these
metrics a lot later on,
once you've implemented a monetization
method and are looking to iterate on it.
So take a moment to think about
what success might look like
for your product.
You'll be referring to these
metrics a lot later on,
once you've implemented a monetization
number and are looking to iterate on it.
So take a moment to think about
what success might look like for
your product, what metrics might you
use to measure customer loyalty,
what percentage of customers do
you reasonably hope to retain.
Use this box to record your response.